This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行在其他地方真的无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，听着去学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，单身汉明星克雷顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。网络侦探们费了一番功夫才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被困之爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立弹性的科学。让自己经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. Thank you so much for tuning in for a really special episode, one that is highly requested. I think people have a lot of questions around this idea of trauma, not just in our 20s, but in our lives in general. It is a super complex, nuanced,
相信你的闺蜜。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（the psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。非常感谢你收听这一期非常特殊、备受期待的节目。我想大家对创伤这个概念有很多疑问，不仅是在我们二十岁的时候，而且在我们的一生中。这是一个超级复杂、微妙的
space and I think there are a lot of misconceptions we see the word trauma being thrown around quite casually but what does it really mean from a psychological perspective? That's what we're here to kind of break down today and I thought it would be important for us to bring on a very special guest someone who knows this space well and who can really provide an evidence based insight and opinion on some of the things we're going to discuss. So without further ado, Dr. Mary Catherine McDonald, thank you so much for joining us, otherwise known as MC, of course. Thank you so much for having me.
空间，我认为有很多误解，我们看到“创伤”这个词被相当随意地抛出，但从心理学的角度来看，它真正意味着什么呢？这就是我们今天要在这里剖析的内容，我想请一位非常特别的嘉宾来节目是很重要的，他非常了解这一领域，并且能够对我们要讨论的一些事情提供基于证据的见解和看法。所以，废话不多说，玛丽·凯瑟琳·麦克唐纳（Mary Catherine McDonald）博士，非常感谢您的加入，当然，她也被称为MC。非常感谢邀请我。
I'm so excited to be here. Yeah. When you reached out, I was like, this is the perfect person to have on the show. Because, yay. Because I do think that it's a question I get a lot. People are really fascinated by trauma. I think everyone has something that we could class. as trauma in their past, but a lot of the information we receive about it is through social media
我很高兴能来到这里。是的。当你联系我时，我觉得这就是上节目的完美人选。因为，耶。因为我觉得这确实是一个我经常被问到的问题。人们对创伤真的很着迷。我认为每个人都有一些在过去可以归类为创伤的事情，但我们收到的关于它的很多信息都是通过社交媒体
is online. And sometimes that can make things, I think, more complicated rather than more accessible. Do you want to give us a little bit of a background and an overview of what you do and how you came to kind of specialize in this area, in this domain? Yes, actually. So I have a very kind of interesting path to trauma. It was not the traditional way. I have an interdisciplinary PhD, so I look at trauma from the perspective of philosophy, psychology, and neuroscience. And I started out looking at identity, and I wanted to think about what identity was composed of. And the specific thing that I was looking at is, like to what extent is our psychology built in story form? And there was this huge debate in the philosophy of psychology at the time about that. And there was one side that was arguing that we are
通过网络获得的。有时这反而会让事情变得更复杂，而不是更容易理解。你想给我们简单介绍一下你的背景，以及你是做什么的，又是如何开始专注于这个领域的吗？是的，其实是的。所以我对创伤的涉足有一个非常有趣的路径。这不是传统的方式。我拥有跨学科的博士学位，所以我从哲学、心理学和神经科学的角度来看待创伤。我最初研究的是身份认同，我想思考身份认同是由什么组成的。我具体研究的是，我们的心理在多大程度上是以故事的形式构建的？当时心理学哲学界在这个问题上有巨大的争论。有一方认为我们
absolutely a coherent story beginning, middle and end. And all of our behaviors for the most part fit into a story beginning middle and end. And it's how we organize the world. And then on the other side, there was this smaller camp arguing that that was not true and that that was harmful. And that if you think of your life as a story that you can actually cause psychological harm to yourself. That side to me seemed incorrect. Like, of course, there's a way in which you could have too tight a story and that could potentially be a problem if you're tying your identity to a singular thing that can cause issues. But it does seem to me to be true that our lives generally follow some kind of story form and that we're always telling a story. And so I reached for trauma actually because I thought it was a case that
绝对是一个前后连贯、有始有终的故事。我们的大部分行为在很大程度上都符合一个有始有终的故事。这是我们组织世界的方式。然后另一方面，有一个较小的阵营认为这不是真的，而且这是有害的。如果你把你的生活想象成一个故事，你实际上可能会对自己的心理造成伤害。在我看来，这一方似乎是不对的。当然，某种程度上你可能会把故事编得太紧，如果你把你的身份绑定到一个单一的事情上，这可能会成为一个问题，从而引发问题。但在我看来，我们的生活大体上遵循某种故事形式，而且我们总是在讲故事，这似乎是真的。所以我之所以关注创伤，其实是因为我认为这是一个案例，
sort of proved that there is a story whether you identify with it or not. Because so many people, when they've been through a traumatic event, talk about how the story gets interrupted or shattered or broken. And so I picked this up and really intended it to be a smaller argument and a larger argument about the nature of the self and identity. And then I fell down this rabbit hole when I realized that the field of psychology still hadn't even decided what kinds of things counted. as trauma and what kinds of things didn't. And so as soon as I leaned into that, I just fell down this rabbit hole. And then I started thinking like, okay, we need to do this better. We need to get clear on what trauma actually is. And then I just sort of moved into the rabbit hole and I have
它某种程度上证明了无论你是否认同它，故事都是存在的。因为有那么多人在经历过创伤事件后，都在谈论故事是如何被中断、粉碎或打破的。所以我拿起这个课题，本来打算对自我和身份的本质做一个小型的论证和一个较大的论证。然后，当我意识到心理学界甚至还没有决定什么样的事情算作创伤、什么样的事情不算时，我就掉进了一个兔子洞。所以一旦我深入研究这个课题，我就直接掉进了这个兔子洞。然后我开始想，好吧，我们需要把这方面做好。我们需要弄清楚创伤到底是什么。然后我就顺势搬进了这个兔子洞，并且
been there ever since. My goodness. Pretty fascinating, pretty fascinating rabbit hole to be and I would say. Yes, absolutely. And it was an interesting time, oh, sorry, to fall into the rabbit hole because at the time I was, you know, I was at Boston University, which is where Bessel van der Kolk was teaching. He wrote the body keeps the score. And yet when my professors heard that I wanted to focus on trauma as my research specialization, they said, you know, everyone knows that the trauma is made up. It's not real. These memories are planted in the minds of patients by the therapist. Oh. And this is, yeah, this was like 2010. It wasn't like 1885. So there's been this huge, like resurgence of discussion, as you mentioned a minute ago on social media and in society
一直呆在那里。我的天哪。这是一个相当迷人、相当迷人的兔子洞，可以说是这样的。是的，绝对的。而且这是一个有趣的时期，哦，抱歉，掉进了这个兔子洞，因为当时我，你知道，我在波士顿大学，贝塞尔·范德科克（Bessel van der Kolk）就是在那儿教书的。他写了《身体记得一切》（the body keeps the score）。然而，当我的一些教授听说我想把创伤作为我的研究专长时，他们说：“你知道的，大家都知道创伤是编造出来的。它不是真的。这些记忆是被治疗师植入患者脑海中的。”哦。而且这，是的，这就像是2010年左右的事。这可不是1885年。所以一直有这样一种巨大的复苏，正如你刚才在社交媒体和社会上提到的那样，
about, you know, the legitimacy of trauma. But I think we have to be really, really careful and make sure that we're actually getting that conversation correct, you know. Yeah, and you really do owe it to, I think everyone in society to not, to only say things such as what those people were saying and such as what those professors were saying when you're completely sure. I'm sure it probably came from a lot of Elizabeth Loftus' work as well around like implanted memories and false memories and things like that. But the idea that we actually don't have a good idea and a good description or categorization of trauma is one that I also find really fascinating. It's so interesting when you look at even the DSM or you look at the diagnoses that psychiatrists
关于，你知道的，创伤的合法性。但我认为我们必须非常非常小心，并确保我们真正把这种对话搞对，你知道的。是的，我觉得你真的对社会上的每个人都负有责任，不要，只说那些人说的话以及那些教授说的话，除非你完全确定。我确信这可能也源于伊丽莎白·洛夫图斯（Elizabeth Loftus）关于植入记忆和虚假记忆等方面的大量工作。但我们对创伤其实并没有一个好的概念、好的描述或分类，这种想法我也觉得非常着迷。当你甚至查看DSM（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）或查看精神科医生可以给出的诊断时，真的是非常有趣
can give it's like PTSD or complex PTSD. and that's kind of the two camps and it's like but what does that really mean because each person is going to need a very I think unique path through that and I think that it is also this movement towards a more holistic way of seeing each individual psychology a more personal way of seeing each person's psychology and trauma is part of that that kind of leads to this question that I have and I'm sure other people have, which is what do you define as trauma? Do you think there is any correct way of labeling a traumatic experience? I do, absolutely.
比如创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）或复杂性创伤后应激障碍（CPSD）。这可以说是两个阵营，但那到底意味着什么呢？因为每个人都需要一条我认为非常独特的康复之路。而且我认为这也是向一种更整体的方式发展的趋势，即以一种更个性化的方式看待每个人的心理，创伤就是其中的一部分，这引发了我有过、其他人也肯定有过的疑问，那就是：你如何定义创伤？你认为给创伤经历贴标签有什么正确的方法吗？是的，绝对有。
But I want to start actually with the incorrect way because I think that the field of psychology and psychiatry is actually getting this wrong. The incorrect way is to make a list of events and say these things are traumatic and that's it. So right now in the DSM, there are three things that are potentially traumatic. There are three potential exposures that you can have to trauma. One is actual or threatened death. The second is serious injury. And the third is sexual violence.
但我其实想从错误的方法开始，因为我认为心理学和精神医学界在这方面其实搞错了。错误的方法是列出一张事件清单，然后说这些事情是创伤，就这样。所以目前在DSM中，有三件事情可能是具有创伤性的。你可能会接触到三种潜在的创伤源。一个是实际的或受到威胁的死亡。第二个是严重受伤。第三个是性暴力。
That's it. Those are the three things. And I think the reason that that's so problematic is because we miss entire populations of people who are showing up with all of the rest of the symptoms of PTSD and not getting diagnosed correctly because they haven't met the criteria for a traumatic stressor. And I think it also reveals that we need to move away from trying to make a list and look instead at responses. William James, who's sort of the father of modern psychology in many ways, described trauma as a thorn in the spirit. And I love this idea because it's a little bit vague, you know, and I think we can move from that and make it more specific so that we don't have this completely vague definition, but that we also don't move to this thing where we're like, okay, these three things are traumatic in any way.
就是这样。这就是那三件事。我认为这之所以如此有问题，是因为我们忽略了整个人群，他们表现出了PTSD的所有其他症状，却未能得到正确的诊断，因为他们不符合创伤应激源的标准。我认为这也表明我们需要摆脱试图列清单的做法，转而关注反应。威廉·詹姆斯（William James），他在许多方面可以说是现代心理学之父，他将创伤描述为“精神上的一根刺”。我非常喜欢这个概念，因为它有点模糊，你知道的，我认为我们可以以此为基础使其更具体，这样我们既不会有一个完全模糊的定义，也不会走向那种认为“好吧，这三件事在任何情况下都是具有创伤性的”而
anything else is not. So the definition that I use is any experience that meets these two criteria. You have an unbearable emotional experience, that's criteria one, that lacks a relational home. That's criteria two. And the reason I like this definition, I've adapted this from a clinician, Robert Stolaro, but the reason I like it is because unbearable raises the bar pretty high. So you can't say that every single experience that you're having, every minor inconvenience, every time you are upset, you can't necessarily say that all of those things are unbearable. So it makes it so that what counts as trauma is sufficiently high so that we don't just kind of stretch the word to the point of meaninglessness and call everything trauma, which I think
其他都不是的地步。所以我使用的定义是：任何满足这两个标准的经历。你有一种难以忍受的情感体验，这是标准一；缺乏一个关系归宿。这是标准二。我喜欢这个定义的原因——我是从临床医生罗伯特·斯托拉罗（Robert Stolaro）那里改编的——我喜欢它的原因是“难以忍受”把标准抬得相当高。所以你不能说你的每一次经历、每一次微小的挫折、你每一次生气的时刻，你不能一定说所有这些事情都是难以忍受的。因此，它使得被视为创伤的标准足够高，这样我们就不会把“创伤”这个词泛化到失去意义的地步，把什么都叫做创伤，我认为
we're in danger of. And the second part is that this idea of a relational home helps us understand, I think, both what we need when we've been exposed to trauma to make sure it doesn't become lasting trauma, and also what we can give each other. And the idea of a relational home is just that our experiences need a dwelling place. And all of them do. Good, good experiences, mediocre experiences, all of them need a dwelling place. When they're too overwhelming for us to find a dwelling place within ourselves, we need other people to relate the event to, to help us figure out where to put it.
我们正面临着这种危险。第二部分是，“关系归宿”这个概念有助于我们理解，我认为，一方面是我们接触到创伤时需要什么来确保它不会变成持久的创伤，另一方面是我们能彼此给予什么。关系归宿的概念就是，我们的经历需要一个栖息地。所有的经历都需要。好的经历、平庸的经历，所有这些都需要一个栖息地。当它们对我们来说过于压抑，以至于无法在内心中找到一个栖息地时，我们就需要其他人来将该事件与之联系起来，帮助我们弄清楚把它放在哪里。
Yeah. Is that kind of like, is that in a sense providing psychological closure, do you think? I can be, yeah. Were you thinking of a particular example? Yeah, well, no, so I was just trying to, because when we talk about relational, I think, I think that's used in a lot of different ways in psychology. And so I think that's so fascinating, that second criteria that you gave. Is there part of the definition that relates to being able to find like an emotional end or some form of closure to the experience that you've been through? For sure. So I think it's.
是的。这有点像，从某种意义上说，是提供心理上的闭环吗？你觉得是这样吗？可以是，是的。你当时想的是某个具体的例子吗？是的，好吧，没有，我只是在试图，因为当我们谈论“关系的”时，我认为，我认为这个词在心理学中有很多不同的用法。所以我认为这太迷了，你给出的第二个标准。定义中是否存在一部分与能够找到某种情感上的终结或对你所经历的经历的某种形式的闭环相关的内容？当然。所以我觉得
essentially trauma is an injury of memory and the injury can happen in one of a million ways, but the symptom, the key central symptom that then comes out in other symptoms in your body and we can talk about later, is that the memory isn't integrated correctly. So if you think of your long-term memory, like a file room, you have all of these memories and they're organized really well so that you can pull them out, you can talk about them, you can assign significance to them and you can put them away with relative ease. So if I ask you, like, what was the favorite, what was your favorite suite when you were growing up? You could probably think about it for a while, tell me a story about someone who made you that thing or who got that for you, what that was
本质上，创伤是记忆的损伤，这种损伤可以通过无数种方式发生，但其症状，即随后在你的身体中表现为其他症状的核心关键症状——我们可以稍后讨论——是记忆没有被正确整合。所以如果你把你的长期记忆想象成一个档案室，你拥有所有这些记忆，它们被组织得非常好，以便你可以把它们抽出来，你可以谈论它们，你可以赋予它们意义，并且你可以相对轻松地把它们放回去。所以如果我问你，比如，当你长大的时候，你最喜欢的套房是什么？你可能会想一会儿，给我讲一个关于某个为你做那件东西或为你买那个东西的人的故事，那是什么
like, and then you can put it away and we can, you know, continue our conversation. That's an integrated memory. And so in a sense, it has closure, it has significance, it has meaning. Trauma memories don't close up like that. They're fragmented because we're too overwhelmed in the moment. And so in to put them away in the organized fashion that we put away all of our other memories. And so we have this strange file that sort of sticks out and either has the wrong significance. It's disorganized in one way or the other. And so it doesn't have closure. We can't close it and put it away.
样的，然后你可以把它收起来，我们可以，你知道的，继续我们的谈话。这是一个整合的记忆。所以从某种意义上说，它有一个闭环，它有重要性，它有意义。创伤记忆不会那样闭合。它们是破碎的，因为我们在当时太不知所措了。因此，无法以我们存放所有其他记忆的那种有组织的方式将它们收起来。因此，我们有了这个奇怪的档案，它有点突兀，要么具有错误的意义。它在这样或那样的方面是杂乱无章的。所以它没有闭环。我们无法将其关闭并收起。
So it remains present in symptoms, intrusion, all of these things. And I think when we are overwhelmed, we need other people to help us, sort those memories and assign significance. So kind of just to work with a silly example, if you have a breakup, let's say your first serious relationship, you think maybe this is someone that you're going to spend the rest of your life with. Maybe you're in your 20s when this happens. It's actually possible. Some people are in your life for getting married. And then the relationship unexpectedly sort of implodes. And you are left now with this fragmented future. You had this, you were telling yourself this story about what this relationship was going to be in your
因此，它以症状、闯入等各种形式持续存在。我认为当我们不知所措时，我们需要其他人来帮助我们整理这些记忆并赋予意义。所以，打个荒谬的比方，如果你经历了一次分手，比方说你的第一段严肃恋爱，你可能认为这个人是你共度余生的人。也许发生这事时你正处于二十岁。这其实是有可能的。有些人出现在你的生命中是为了结婚。然后这段关系出乎意料地崩溃了。你现在留下了这个破碎的未来。你一直在对自己讲述关于这段关系在你的生命中会是什么样的故事，
life and now you have to shift the meaning, the significance, and get closure. Sometimes that's provided in the breakup. Sometimes it isn't. Sometimes your friends help you figure out how to get that closure and put that away so that relationship doesn't stay central and present or signify to you that like you should always be alone or should never date again or any of these things. Does that make sense? It does make a lot of sense. And I think actually this idea of breakups as being traumatic is something that I see a lot. And I think we used to, I think that we used to use that phrase or the term trauma, trauma or traumatic. When we were referring to things that I think we can all very easily see and very easily identify as being unbearable, the one I always think about is, you know, people who come back
而现在你必须改变意义、重要性并获得闭环。有时这是在分手时提供的。有时则不然。有时你的朋友会帮你弄清楚如何获得闭环并把那段经历收起来，这样这段关系就不会一直处于核心和现在的位置，或者向你暗示你应该永远一个人呆着，或者再也不要约会了，或者诸如此类的事情。这说得通吗？这确实很有道理。而且我认为实际上，将分手视为具有创伤性这种想法是我经常看到的。并且我认为过去，我认为我们过去常常使用那个短语或术语“创伤”、“创伤的”或者“创伤性的”。当我们指的是那些我认为我们大家都能非常轻易地看到并非常轻易地识别为难以忍受的事情时，我总是想到的是，你知道的，那些从
from serious conflict or come back for more on their veterans and they have PTSD. And now I see it becoming a lot more part of our dialogue in relation to the things that I think a lot of us go through, breakups being one of them. You know, that breakup was so traumatic. Oh, my God, that guy traumatized me. What do you think, why do you think that has become more common? Do you think that trauma and our interpretation of trauma has changed for this current generation? because I don't know, I'm on the fence here because I've,
严酷冲突中归来或退伍的老兵，他们患有PTSD。而现在我看到它越来越多地成为我们对话的一部分，涉及那些我认为我们很多人都会经历的事情，分手就是其中之一。你知道，“那次分手太创伤了。哦，天哪，那家伙创伤了我。”你觉得，你认为为什么这变得更常见了？你认为创伤以及我们对创伤的解释对这一代人来说已经改变了吗？因为我不知道，我对此持观望态度，因为我
yeah, have used the phrase, oh, that was traumatic to explain the end of relationships. And your explanation of what that meant, that fragmented memory, it really does kind of, it really does resonate with me. But do you think that the more colloquial use of the term trauma or the term traumatic, our use of it in this current generation, firstly, what do you think that came from? And do you think that is a good thing for the psychology and the progress around how we interpret trauma? It's such a good question, a double part question. I'll answer the first part first of where did it come from.
是的，也曾用过“哦，那太创伤了”这个词来解释一段关系的结束。而你对这意味着什么的解释，那种破碎的记忆，确实非常，确实非常引起我的共鸣。但你是否认为，更通俗地使用“创伤”或“创伤性的”这个词，我们这一代人对它的使用，首先，你认为这源于什么？你认为这对于心理学以及我们如何解释创伤的进展来说是一件好事吗？这是一个很好的问题，一个包含两个部分的问题。我先回答第一部分，也就是它源于哪里。
I think we need to think about that because it's very easy to judge it. And I do this. So I just had a book that came out called Unbroken. The trauma response is never wrong. And in it, I say that, you know, words really matter. And we need to, we don't want to stretch the word trauma to the point of meaninglessness because then we stop studying it. Then it becomes like the common cold. We won't spend any research dollars. We won't try to heal from it. It'll just be part of human existence. And that's really dangerous because it is
我认为我们需要思考这个问题，因为这很容易去评判。而我也会这样做。所以我的新书刚出版，书名叫《未破损》（Unbroken）。创伤反应永远不会错。在书中，我说过，你知道的，词语真的很重要。我们需要，我们不希望把“创伤”这个词泛化到失去意义的地步，因为那样我们就不会再去研究它了。然后它就会变得像普通感冒一样。我们将不会投入任何研究资金。我们将不会试图从中恢复。它只会成为人类生存的一部分。这真的很危险，因为它在许多情况下是生死攸关的事。
in many cases a life or death situation. And so I use in the book some examples that are funny, you know, when my students tell me that they're traumatized by a chemistry exam or by the dorm food or by their roommates, like sleeping patterns or whatever. And I'm like, really, is it really traumatic? Like, let's give me the context there. But I think rather than judge it, it's important to look at like this question of why are we reaching for the this hyperbolic language to explain relatively mundane experiences that seems like a relevant thing you know like is it that we don't feel legitimate unless we have something that's hyperbolic and huge are we trying to express something that's going on sort of in a in a collective unconscious way like we are living in a
所以在书中我使用了一些有趣的例子，你知道的，当我的学生告诉我他们被化学考试、宿舍里的食物或者他们室友的睡眠习惯等事情创伤时，我说：“真的吗，这真的是创伤吗？来，给我点上下文。”但比起评判，更重要的是去探究这样一个问题：为什么我们要用这种夸张的语言来解释相对平凡的经历？这似乎是一个相关的事情，你知道的，是不是因为如果我们没有某种夸张且巨大的经历，我们就感觉自己不合法？我们是否在试图表达某种以集体无意识方式发生的事情？就像我们生活在一个
really overwhelming time so are we trying to match that general feeling to our, you know, events in our day-to-day lives? I don't know. But I think it has benefits and it has disadvantages. The benefits of more people talking about trauma is that more people are talking about trauma. And so that makes it less likely that people will feel really like too stigmatized to get help when they need it. It raises awareness. It normalizes that this is an experience. And again, we have to be careful of how we're using it. And I think When it comes to breakups in particular, I think some breakups really are traumatic. The book is organized by each chapter has a case study and then some explanation and then a
真正让人不知所措的时代，所以我们是在试图将那种普遍的感受与我们日常生活的事件相匹配吗？我不知道。但我认为它有好处也有坏处。更多人谈论创伤的好处在于，更多人开始谈论创伤了。这使得人们在需要时不太会因为感到耻辱而不敢寻求帮助。它提高了意识。它使这成为一种正常的经历，并且再次强调，我们必须注意我们是如何使用它的。我认为特别是说到分手，我觉得有些分手确实是创伤性的。这本书的组织结构是每一章都有一个案例研究，然后是一些解释，接着是
couple of tools to help the reader heal from whatever they're going through. And one of the chapters is about referred pain. Do you know about this in biology? Yeah, I actually do. But explain it for the audience as well. So referred pain is a really strange biological thing whereby you might have like the classic example is if you have jaw pain and you go to the dentist and you think, oh, maybe I've got a root canal or I have some sort of abscess or something going on. And they tell you that you need to go to the
几个帮助读者从他们正在经历的事情中恢复过来的工具。其中有一章讲的是“牵涉痛”（referred pain）。你在生物学中听说过这个吗？是的，我其实知道。但请也为听众解释一下。所以牵涉痛是一种非常奇怪的生物学现象，比如你可能会有——典型的例子是如果你有下巴痛，你去看牙医，你心想，哦，也许我有根管治疗的问题，或者我有什么脓肿之类的毛病。他们却告诉你，你需要去
emergency room because even though the pain is in your jaw, you're actually having a heart attack. Or you might have pain in your shoulder and it's actually a result of your spleen. So the source of the pain and the pain don't necessarily match up. And so I've seen this with many, many clients where they will come in and say, you know, I'm working as a first responder and I love my job, but I'm having nightmares, and I think I might need to quit my job. And then we start to dive more deeply into it. And it's not the job that's traumatic. It's the breakup that they just had because they were planning a future with someone who then unexpectedly turned around and waltzed out of their life and sort of smashed their future to bits. And so, of course, not all breakups
急诊室，因为尽管痛在下巴，但你实际上正在心脏病发作。或者你的肩膀可能会痛，而这实际上是你的脾脏引起的。因此，痛的来源和疼痛本身并不一定吻合。所以我看到过很多很多的客户，他们会走进来对我说：“你知道的，我是一名急救人员，我热爱我的工作，但我一直在做噩梦，我想我可能需要辞职了。”然后我们开始更深入地探讨。结果不是工作具有创伤性。而是他们刚刚经历的分手，因为他们一直在和一个原本计划共度未来的人在一起，而那个人却出乎意料地转身大步走出了他们的生活，把他们的未来砸得粉碎。所以，当然，并不是所有的分手
are going to be traumatic necessarily, just like not all war experiences are traumatic. Not everybody that comes back. You can see exactly why it's so problematic to define trauma based on the event because it falls apart immediately. How does it make sense if war is traumatic inherently that some soldiers come back without PTSD? You know? And so I think that we just need more nuance in the conversation. And I know that's a value that you have. Thank you. So I think that it's that it's really important that we look not at kind of what happened, but what sorts of reverberations the event is causing? What sort of traces did it leave? Yeah, I really love that. The idea of referred pain is one that I really do need to speak about more because I do think,
都必然具有创伤性，就像并非所有的战争经历都具有创伤性一样。并不是每一个回来的人……你可以确切地看到为什么根据事件来定义创伤是如此成问题，因为它马上就会土崩瓦解。如果战争本质上是创伤性的，为什么有些士兵回来后没有患上PTSD？这怎么讲得通呢？你知道吗？所以我觉得我们需要在对话中有更多的细微差别。我知道这也是你所珍视的价值观。谢谢。所以我认为，这非常重要，我们不应该看发生了什么，而是看事件正在引起什么样的余波？它留下了什么样的痕迹？是的，我真的很喜欢那个。牵涉痛的概念是我真的很想更多地谈论的一个概念，因为我确实认为，
especially in our 20s, right, we all, there are so many huge life transitions. We are like experiencing the world as adults for the first time with an air of independence. So I do think that our kind of grasp on things is inherently quite shaky. So things can very easily disturb our sense of control over our situation and disturb how we are consolidating our long-term memories and how we are creating the narrative for our life. Do you think that there are some people who are innately more likely to experience trauma or interpret events as traumatic based on certain attributes of theirs
尤其是在我们的二十岁时，对吧，我们都有，有那么多重大的生活转变。我们就像是以一种独立的姿态第一次以成人的身份体验世界。所以我确实认为我们对事物的把握本质上是相当不稳固的。所以事情很容易扰乱我们对自身处境的控制感，并扰乱我们如何巩固我们的长期记忆以及如何为我们的生活创造叙事。你认为有些人是否由于他们自身的某些属性、气质或个性，天生更有可能经历创伤或将事件解释为具有创伤性？是的。请多解释一点，因为我对此太着迷了。我经常思考这个问题。
or their temperament or their personality? Yes. Please explain more because I'm so fascinated by this. I think about this quite a bit. Right? And so the first thing I want to say is that I think like the 20s is one of the hardest decades of life. And I think it's no one really,
对吧？我要说的第一件事是，我认为二十岁是人生中最艰难的十年之一。我认为没有人真正，
not enough people talk about it that way because people are like, oh, the world is your oyster and you have so many opportunities and you don't have to settle down and everything is open to you. But what they're missing when they say those things, which are true, is that it's also terrifying. Yeah. And isolating and confusing. And there are missteps and mistakes that feel catastrophic. And so the 20s is a very intense decade.
没有足够多的人以这种方式谈论它，因为人们会说，“哦，世界是你的广阔天地，你有这么多的机会，你不必安定下来，一切都向你敞开。”但他们在说这些话——虽然这些话是真的——时所忽略的是，这也是极其可怕的。是的。而且让人感到孤立和困惑。会有一些感觉像灾难一样的失误和错误。所以二十岁是一个非常激烈的十年。
I remember, thankfully, I had a therapist tell me that when I was in the midst of my 20s, which were extremely turbulent. And I thought, okay, if I can just get to my 30s, some of this will calm down, you know, which is true and false, of course. But so I think that that decade is an area where there is a lot of possibility for trauma. And I think in some sense, the shortest answer to your question about like who is more likely to experience PTSD
我记得，谢天谢地，在我二十多岁的时候，曾有一位治疗师对我说过这句话，当时我的生活极其动荡。我想，好吧，如果我能熬到三十岁，这些情况就会有所平息，你知道的，当然这既对又错。所以我觉得那个十年是一个充满创伤可能性的领域。而且我认为从某种意义上说，对于你关于“谁更有可能经历PTSD”或“谁更有可能真正与创伤作斗争”的问题，最简短的回答是，我们不知道，但我们知道有些人比其他人更有弹性。
or to really struggle with trauma is that we don't know, but we know that some people are more resilient than that. others. And it's likely that there are like 48 layers that contribute to what makes someone resilient. And there are researchers who are trying to figure that out. And some of them are pointing to really, you know, singular explanations. And they're saying like, look, some people have more glucocorticoid steroid receptors in their brain. And therefore, they're more likely to experience trauma. Some people have less. And so they're less likely. And that's, of course, probably a layer. But I think you have to add to that what was the you know what were the developmental years like what is the support
而且很可能有48层因素促成了造就坚韧不拔的特质。有些研究人员正试图弄清楚这一点。其中一些人正指向非常单一的解释。他们说，看，有些人大脑中有更多的糖皮质激素受体。因此，他们更有可能经历创伤。有些人比较少。所以他们可能性较小。当然，这可能只是其中一层。但我认为你必须在此基础上加上：发育期是怎样的？支持系统是怎样的？你是否具有僵化的性格特质或开放性？在多大程度上——所以其中许多事情都在一定程度上存在于光谱上；
system like do you have rigidity as a personality trait or openness and to what extent like so many of these things kind of occur on spectrum so um i think that one of the things that gets in the way of healing is rigidity um but that's again just one layer that i happen to be fascinated with because i don't know that much about glucocorticochorticoid steroid receptors you know like there's It's just, right? It's not the word I tend to use often. Right, yeah. So I think it's going to turn out that as we study resilience and try to figure out what makes
所以，我认为阻碍康复的原因之一是僵化——但这再次只是我恰好着迷的一个层面，因为我对糖皮质激素受体了解得不是那么多，你知道的，就像——这并不是我经常使用的词。对，是的。所以我想随着我们研究弹性并试图弄清楚是什么让更多人自然而然地更具弹性，我们会发现有很多很多事情我们可以做。这其实是非常有希望的，因为这也意味着我们可能可以调高某些事情和某些特质的音量，并帮助我们自己，你知道的。你真的很想说服我去这个领域攻读博士学位。我真的不撒谎。哦，你应该谈谈这个。我们应该在镜头外、在播客之外谈谈这个。
more people sort of naturally more resilient, that we will find that there are many, many things that we can do. And that's really quite hopeful because then that also means that we can probably turn up the volume on certain things and certain traits and help ourselves, you know. You're really selling me on doing like a P. in this area. I'm not going to lie. Oh, you should talk about that. We should talk about that off screen, off the podcast.
因为就像，我认为弹性真的是一个黑匣子，对吧？这里面包含诸如童年经历之类的事情，这些经历是如此完全独特，而我们还没有对它们进行适当的测绘。我与之交谈过的每一个人，我想我从未在这个节目的任何身份下与任何人交谈过，他们没有将童年指出为我们生活中正在发生的事情、当前的事情以及我们二十岁甚至三十岁或更久的事情的根源。然而，我们确实对它包含什么没有太多概念。我想就像你解释创伤的方式一样，我们真的认为它就像具体的事件。
Because it's like, I think resilience is this really, this bit of like a black box, right? And in that is things like childhood experiences, which are so entirely unique and which we have not properly mapped. Everyone I speak to, I don't think I have ever spoken to someone. in any capacity on this show who has not pointed to childhood as the origin of something that is going on in our lives, something current and something in our 20s or even in our 30s or beyond. And yet we really don't have much of an idea of what it contains. I think much like how you were explaining trauma, we really see it as like specific events.
所以诸如虐待、忽视，甚至经常搬家的事情。有那么多小的、非常能改变生活轨迹的沙粒卡在齿轮里。我们没有做足够的探索。童年的霸凌。我可以滔滔不绝地讲下去。我认为这个播客为我提供了如此多的轶事证据，证明我们需要进行更深入、更细微的讨论。因为有这么多人来找我，说，“这件事发生在我身上。这似乎完全是独一无二的，
So things like abuse or things like neglect or even people who move quite a bit. there are so many small, very life-changing, like, grains of sand that get stuck in the clogs. We don't explore enough. The childhood bullying. Like, I could go on and on and on. And I think this podcast, it provides me with so much anecdotal evidence for the fact that we need to have a more in-depth and nuanced discussion. Because so many people come to me and they say, this thing has happened to me. It seems entirely unique.
真的没有关于我这种特定经历的文献。你能给我解释一下吗？”然后这真的很搞笑，因为你可能会看那个然后觉得，“哇，这上面什么也没有。太不幸了。”但随后第二天就会有另一个人发信息给你，有着完全相同的经历。然而，这并没有被谈论。我知道。
there is really no literature on my specific experience. Can you explain it for me? And then it's really interesting because you might look at that and be like, wow, like there is nothing on this. That's so unfortunate. But then you'll have someone else message you the next day with the exact same experience. And yeah, it's not spoken about. I know.
这表明了一个观点，即当我们看待心理学作为一门科学的方式时，我们需要非常小心。因为我们对它抱有一种精确性和真理性的期望，而这是它所无法提供的。是的，绝对不能。我认为你可以使用尽可能多的研究和尽可能多的统计显着性。
And it's that points to the idea that like we need to be really careful when it comes to the way that we look at psychology as a science. Yeah. Because we expect a kind of, um, precision and truth from it that it does not provide. Yeah, absolutely not. I think that's, you can use as many studies and as many statistical significances as you want.
但我也认为这是其中之一，这是一个争论点：我们是否应该把心理学变成一门真正的科学——我认为它确实是。我们是否应该在我们所做的每一件事中加入更多那些实验性的特征？还是我们应该允许它保持，
Yeah. But I think that is also one of those things where it is, this is kind of off topic, but there is this like battle of like, do we make psychology a proper science, which I think it is. Do we add in more of those experimental features to every single thing that we're doing? Or do we allow it to maintain,
保持这种可塑的、灵活的、几乎是跨学科的“松软”特性？不，但这太迷人了。这回到了这样一个问题：我们在美国研究逆境童年经历（ACEs）。我不知道这在国际上达到了什么程度。事实上，有趣的是，我们做了第一次澳大利亚儿童虐待研究，我是采访者之一。所以这就对了。哦，太棒了。
to maintain this kind of moldable, flexible, almost like interdisciplinary kind of squishiness to it. No, but it's so fascinating. And it goes back to the thing of like, so we study adverse childhood experiences here in the U.S. I don't know how far that has reached internationally. Actually, interestingly, we did the first Australian child maltreatment study and I was one of the interviewers. So there we go. Oh, amazing.
是的。好的，所以你对这一切了如指掌。我对这项研究了如指掌。太好了。这并不好，但对社会来说是好的。是的。是的。但另一件事是，我不记得最初的逆境童年经历研究是什么时候出来的了，可能是90年代。是美国凯撒保险公司（Kaiser insurance company）想要研究创伤经历对寿命和健康的影响。作为一家保险公司，他们对此有着切身利益，对吧？他们想知道如果你来自一个更有可能经历逆境童年经历的地区，我们在保险上是否应该
Yeah. Okay, so you know all about this. I know all about this study. So good. It's so fast. Not good, but good for society. Yes. Yeah. But the other thing is that I can't remember when the original adverse childhood experiences came out was maybe the 90s. It was Kaiser insurance company in the U.S. that wanted to look at the impact of traumatic experiences on longevity and health. Because as an insurance company, they have a stake in this, right? They want to know if you're from an area where you're more likely to have adverse childhood experiences, should we
承保你。所以从一开始，研究设计就存在问题。但随后没有人关注积极的童年经历。直到2018年左右，甚至没有人想到去研究这些经历以及它们如何能够对抗逆境童年经历。所以从90年代或者逆境童年经历研究第一次问世的任何时候开始，一直到2018年——我可能把年份记错了，但这很长时间——没有人想过，“嘿，我刚才提到沙粒，你生活中的人们所产生的积极影响呢？你生命中那些如此鼓舞人心的老师呢？你所属的朋友和你们一起玩的团队运动等等所有这些呢？”所以一旦他们开始研究
cover you and insurance-wise. So there's problems in the study designed from the jump. But then no one looked at positive childhood experiences. No one even thought to look at that and how they might counter adverse childhood experiences until like 2018. So all the way from like the 90s or whenever the first time was that the adverse childhood experiences study came out until 2018, I'm probably getting the years wrong, but it was a long time. No one thought, hey, I'm talking about grains of sand you said a second ago what about the positive impacts of the people that you have in your life what about the teachers that you have that are so inspiring what about the friends that you belong to and the team sports that you play and all of this stuff and so as soon as they start looking at
这个，数据当然就完全变了。是的。所以这就有一种观点，即“再次重申，心理学是一门基于研究的科学，而研究的好坏取决于研究设计。”我简直起鸡皮疙瘩了。只有心理学家才能对这句话起鸡皮疙瘩。对的。我当时想，你说得太对了。我在节目中经常谈到“保护因素”（protective factors），因为整个节目的宗旨——《你二十岁的心理学》——就是让你明白：你有自主权。你无法改变你的童年发生过的事情。
that of course the data completely changes yeah so there's this idea that like again you know psychology is a is a study-based science and studies are only good as study design that is i literally got chills Only a psychology known can get chills at that phrase. Right. I'm like, you're so spot on. I talk about protective factors on this show so much because the whole aim of this, of the psychology of your 20s is to be like, you have agency. You cannot change what has happened in your childhood.
尽管这令人遗憾，但你无法回去重写你所经历的经历。但我们每个人都有自主权，我们每个人生命中都有一些东西，发生在我们身上的事情、导师、我们物理环境中的某种东西、某种激励我们的东西，它保护我们免受围绕这些经历的一些负面影响。我认为这确实表明了心理学在某些领域是多么未被探索，并且仍有许多方面处于未知的状态。这就像深海潜水。是的， exatamente。而且我们对大脑和神经科学了解得越多，我们就越意识到大脑具有可塑性，远比我们想象的要多。所以即使你确实有逆境童年经历，也并不意味着这些事情是根深蒂固的。从神经生物学的角度来看，对于我们如何处理这些经历、这些经历如何转化为行为以及我们如何干预这些事情，我们拥有大得多的自主权。我们只是，我们需要把这些信息传达给每个人，因为如果你不知道这一点，你就不会去寻求改变。
As unfortunate as it is, you cannot go back and rework the experiences that you had. But each of us does have agency and each of us does have things in our life, things that happen to us, mentors, something in our physical environment, something that inspired us that protects us against some of the negativity around those experiences. I think it really does kind of go to show how much, I think psychology is just so unexplored in some domains and there are still so many aspects of it that are kind of uncharted. It's like deep ocean diving. Yeah, exactly. And the more we learn about the brain and neuroscience, the more we realize that the brain is malleable, far more than we thought it was. So even if you did have adverse childhood experiences, it doesn't mean that those things are hardwired. We have far more agency, even just from a neurobiological perspective over what we do with those experiences and how those turn into behaviors and how we can intervene on those things. We just, we need to get that information out to everybody because if you don't know that, then you don't seek the chance.
尽管不幸，你无法回到过去重新加工你的经历。但我们每个人都有自主权，我们生活中的某些人、发生的某些事、导师、物理环境中的某物、某个激发我们灵感的事物，都能保护我们免受那些经历带来的负面影响。我认为这确实表明，心理学在某些领域是多么未被充分探索，仍有许多方面属于未知领域。这就像深海潜水一样。是的，完全正确。我们对大脑和神经科学了解得越多，就越意识到大脑是具有可塑性的，远比我们想象的要强。因此，即使你确实有过不良的童年经历，也并不意味着这些事情是无法改变的。即使从神经生物学的角度来看，对于我们如何处理这些经历、它们如何转化为行为以及我们如何进行干预，我们也拥有大得多的自主权。我们只是，我们需要把这些信息传达给每个人，因为如果你不知道这一点，你就不会去寻找这个机会。
change. Yeah, neuroplasticity is so, I think it's something that people don't understand. I think we tend to think that our brain, we hit 25, it's fully developed. We have all the neurons that we'll ever have, but there is so much like synaptic pruning and rewiring going on. I guess this kind of brings me to my next question, because I want to re-centre us on this discussion around trauma. What is kind of the impact of trauma on the mind, but also on the body? How does it manifest in sometimes our biology but just in our physical responses. Yes. So it's really important to understand that as we go into this,
改变。是的，神经可塑性太——我觉得这是人们不太理解的一点。我觉得我们往往认为，大脑在25岁时就已经完全发育成熟了。我们拥有了这辈子会拥有的所有神经元，但实际上其中发生了大量的突触修剪和神经重连。我想这顺便带出了我的下一个问题，因为我想把话题重新聚焦到关于创伤的讨论上。创伤对心理，以及对身体有什么样的影响？它有时是如何表现在我们的生物学特性中，又如何表现在我们的身体反应中的？是的。所以非常重要的一点是要明白，在我们深入探讨之前，
that we stop separating the mind from the body because the two things are in a dynamic unity and they're always along for the ride. So anything you're talking about that's happening in the mind is also having some impact on the body. So we are designed to toggle between stress and relaxation. And that's just by nature. We've evolved that way. This is one of the reasons why one of my big things is that the trauma response is actually not a sign of weakness or disorder. It's a sign of strength because the first responses that then can become over time maladaptive and turn into symptoms are there to keep you alive.
我们应该停止将心理与身体割裂开来，因为这两者是一个动态的整体，它们总是形影不离的。所以你谈论的任何在心理上发生的事情，其实也都会对身体产生某种影响。因此，我们的身体生来就能在压力和放松之间自由切换。这是自然而然的。我们就是这样进化而来的。这也是为什么我一直坚持的一个核心观点是：创伤反应实际上并不是软弱或失调的标志。它恰恰是力量的象征，因为那些最初可能会随着时间推移变得适应不良并演变成症状的反应，其存在是为了让你活下去。
Yeah. And so we toggle between high stress and relaxation because that's an adaptive way to be in the world and engage with different circumstances and environments that are more. more or less threatening. And so a very silly example is that my house is sort of nestled into the woods. And so every now and then there's a deer right outside my bedroom window at three o'clock in the morning. And a deer right outside your bedroom at three o'clock in the morning sounds like two fully grown humans standing outside your bedroom window at three o'clock in the morning, right? We don't have D here. I have no idea. I would be like, baby. Yeah, exactly. But just bigger and louder. And so at three o'clock in the morning, I am at my my most relaxed. My nervous system is toggled all, basically all the way down. My heart rate is at
是的。所以我们在高压和放松之间切换，因为这是在世界上生存、并与不同环境进行互动的适应性方式，而这些环境或多或少都带有一些威胁性。一个非常生动的例子是，我的房子坐落在树林里。所以每隔一段时间，凌晨三点钟，我的卧室窗户外就会出现一只鹿。而凌晨三点钟卧室窗外出现一只鹿，听起来就像是两个成年人站在你卧室窗外一样，对吧？我们没有鹿。我不知道。我会觉得，天哪。是的，完全是这样。只不过它更大、声音更响。所以在凌晨三点钟，我处于最放松的状态。我的神经系统基本上完全放松了下来。我的心率降到了
its lowest. Breathing rate is at its lowest. All of this stuff is at its lowest. And then I hear a noise. And an alarm system goes off in my brain and body and reprioritizes all of the functions in my brain and body to help me adapt to that threat. And so I go from lowest nervous system activation to highest in less than a second. And you know this because if you've ever been woken up in the middle of the night, you are sometimes like across the room before you're fully awake. Yeah. It's like what is it? It's your sympathetic nervous system like your flight of flight response is so ridiculously alert. It's so fast. Yeah. And that is the kind of the command center of the stress response system. And so when that happens in the middle of the night, I go from relaxed to really stressed to really
最低水平。呼吸频率降到了最低。所有这些指标都处于最低点。然后我听到了一声噪声。我的大脑和身体里的警报系统瞬间拉响，并重新调配了大脑和身体中的所有功能，以帮助我应对这种威胁。于是，我在不到一秒钟的时间里，从神经系统激活度最低的状态直接飙升到了最高状态。你知道这种感觉，因为如果你曾在半夜被吵醒过，有时你甚至还没完全清醒就已经跑到房间另一头了。是的。这就像是，怎么回事？这是你的交感神经系统——也就是你的战斗或逃跑反应——它是如此高度警觉，反应极其迅速。是的。这就是压力反应系统的指挥中心。所以当这种情况在半夜发生时，我从放松状态转变为高度紧张，然后再转变为高度
relaxed within a matter of minutes. Like I can usually, as soon as I realize it's a deer, within 10 or 15 minutes, I'd go back to sleep. And that's how we're designed, because you couldn't stay in full stress all the time, and you wouldn't want to stay in full relaxation all the time, because then you're not adapting to your environment. When we get stuck in stress, when fighter flight gets switched on and stays on, this creates chronic inflammation in the body, which leads to all sorts of symptoms and breakdowns in the systems of the body that can result in a set of symptoms that is maddening because they can look really disconnected and not related to stress at all. And often we think that they are disease independent of stress and often
放松，只需要几分钟的时间。比如通常情况下，一旦我意识到那只鹿，在10到15分钟内，我就能重新入睡。这就是我们的生理设计，因为你不可能一直处于高度紧张状态，你也不会想一直处于完全放松状态，因为那样你就无法适应环境了。当我们陷入压力中无法自拔，当战斗或逃跑反应被开启并持续不断时，这会在体内产生慢性炎症，从而导致各种症状，并引发身体系统的崩溃，进而产生一系列让人抓狂的症状，因为它们看起来可能毫无关联，甚至与压力一点关系也没有。而且我们经常认为这些是独立于压力之外的疾病，但实际上
they are disease that is related to stress. And so since we're designed to toggle back and forth when we get stuck, that that's when we have problems. And so that is what contributes to sort of the impact of trauma on the body. And that can result in like chronic pain, gastrointestinal issues, sleep disorders, infertility. Like the list is just massive. In the mind, if we go back to the memory files, now we kind of have to move away from the deer experience because that's pretty easy to integrate what happened. I can tell the story about it. I can put it away, all that stuff. But when I have something that's significantly overwhelming, the one of the adaptations that my brain and body move into and that overwhelm is that they shut down
它们往往是与压力息息相关的疾病。所以，既然我们的身体生来就是为了来回切换，那么当我们陷入其中无法自拔时，问题就出现了。这就是导致创伤对身体产生影响的原因。这可能会导致慢性疼痛、肠胃问题、睡眠障碍、不孕不育等等。这样的例子简直不胜枚举。在心理层面，如果我们回到记忆档案室，现在我们得把那头鹿的经历抛开，因为那个经历很容易整合，发生了什么我都能讲出来。我可以把它讲成一个故事，然后把它存档，诸如此类。但当遭遇了极其严重、令人不知所措的事件时，大脑和身体产生的一种适应性机制就是，它们会关闭
the recording system in the brain. And so that file room, like all the people that work in the file room, run out of the file room to go help with the emergency. And so the result is that you have this unintegrated file, this file that's missing pieces. It either has holes in the story, maybe there's no emotional content, or it doesn't have the right meaning assigned to it. those are kind of the three things that all of our memory files need. And so as an attempt to reorganize the memory, your mind, anytime it's in the presence of something that looks familiar from that memory, will push that memory to the front of your mind and say, hey, here's this file again, right?
大脑中的录制系统。于是，那个档案室就像是档案室里的所有员工都跑出去帮忙处理紧急情况了一样。结果就是，你留下了一份未被整合的档案，一份缺少关键片段的档案。它要么在故事上有漏洞，要么可能缺乏情感内容，要么就是没有被赋予正确的意义。这正是我们所有的记忆档案所需的三个要素。因此，为了试图重新整理这段记忆，你的大脑只要遇到任何与那段记忆中看似熟悉的事物相似的场景，就会把这段记忆推到你的脑海最前端，然后说：“嘿，这个档案又出现了，对吧？”
That color red reminds me of this scary thing that we never integrated. Let's integrate it. The problem is the, you know, fight or flight system in your brain, you're, you're, you know, amygdala and limbic system recognize that as danger and they're off to the races again. And so that's why memory can kind of put you into this chronic fight or flight. Wow. That is such a great explanation. I think the one thing I really want to point to there was when you talked about the color red, like the role of triggers as well. And I think that that is so, such an interesting way to put it is that triggers are basically the environment reminding your
那个红色的颜色让我想起了那件我们从未整合过的可怕事情。让我们把它整合了吧。问题是，你大脑中的战斗或逃跑系统——也就是你的杏仁核和边缘系统——会将那识别为危险，然后再次全速运转。这就是为什么记忆有时会把你推入这种慢性的战斗或逃跑状态中。哇。这真是一个极好的解释。我想特别指出的一点是，刚才你谈到红色时，提到了触发因素（triggers）的作用。我觉得这是一种非常有趣的说法：触发因素基本上就是环境在提醒你的
brain that there are things that it has not yet figured out. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. And it's, we should think of them as like in, you know, like the indicator light in your car. Yeah. When that goes off, you don't just get out of the car and leave your car in the highway. Right? I don't know. Sometimes I do. You might want to. Yeah. But you're like, oh, something, something needs to be looked at. Let's take this to the mechanic and look at it. So there's, there's so many misconceptions when it comes to triggers. And that's, I think, one of the primary dangers of when we talk about trauma incorrectly. Yeah.
大脑，有些事情它还没有理清楚。完全正确。是的。是的。我们应该把它们看作是，你知道的，就像你车里的故障指示灯一样。是的。当指示灯亮起时，你不会直接跳下车把车扔在高速公路上，对吧？我不知道。有时候我确实会。你可能真想这么干。是的。但你会觉得，哦，有什么地方出问题了，需要检查一下。我们得把它送去修理厂检查一下。所以，在面对触发因素时，存在着这么多的误解。我认为，这正是我们以错误的方式谈论创伤时所带来的主要危险之一。是的。
But it's interesting because you say that analogy of like, let's take it to the mechanic and get it looked at. But sometimes I, and please correct me if I'm wrong, you obviously know a lot more than me on this topic. But I feel like sometimes with the coping mechanisms that we use, particularly around suppression, mean that people really don't want to look into the engine. Because like, is there a part of it that is so traumatic sometimes
但有趣的是，你用了“把它送到修理厂检查一下”这种比喻。但有时我——如果我理解错了请纠正我，在这个话题上你显然比我懂得多得多——但我感觉，有时通过我们使用的应对机制，特别是压抑机制，导致人们真的不想去检查发动机。因为，是否存在这样一种情况，有时经历的事情是如此具有创伤性，
that our brain eliminate, needs the memory and like completely shuts off from connecting with it. I think the the example I always think of is people who talk about suppressed memories that things traumatic things that have happened in childhood they don't remember until they're in their 20s or 30s. I know it is quite controversial these days that kind of field and that understanding of that but do you think that sometimes our mind does really conceal traumatic events from us consciously? Absolutely. Absolutely. I mean, I think, so the trauma response is adaptive. Its main goal, like if it was a video game, is to protect you and make it more likely that you stay alive. And so if it can reduce pain, if it can reduce exposure to threat, it will do that. And that feels to us sometimes disorganized. And it feels like, because we've labeled it this way incorrectly, it feels like a sign of weakness or disorder. But it's so critical to understand that. Biologically, it is adaptation. And so when you're a kid, especially, I mean, maybe not especially, maybe this is just a more vivid example,
以至于我们的大脑需要抹去这段记忆，并完全切断与它的联系？我想我脑海中一直浮现的例子是那些谈论被压抑记忆的人，他们在童年遭遇了创伤事件，直到二十多岁或三十多岁才想起来。我知道现在在这个领域和这种理解上还有相当大的争议，但你认为有时我们的大脑真的会在意识层面将创伤事件对我们隐瞒起来吗？绝对会。绝对会。我的意思是，创伤反应本身就是一种适应机制。它的主要目标——如果把这比作一个电子游戏的话——就是保护你，让你更有可能活下来。因此，如果它能减少痛苦，如果它能减少对威胁的暴露，它就会这么做。有时在我们看来，这显得杂乱无章。而且因为我们给它贴上了错误的标签，它感觉像是一种软弱或失调的标志。但非常关键的一点是要明白：从生物学角度来说，这是一种适应。因此，当你还是个孩子的时候，尤其是——也许不只是尤其是，这只是一个更生动的例子——
but when you're a child, if you're exposed to something that you have no language for that is so overwhelming that your system decides you have to be taken out at that moment in order to survive, it will do that. And so this is essentially the freeze response where you will dissociate and disconnect from the experience and actually not really fully experience it. And your brain, I think that our brains, I think this is miraculous. Like I think we've gotten it so wrong when we label it as disorder because it's a miracle that there's something in your system that's like, you know what, this, we're going to opt out of this.
但当你还是个孩子时，如果你暴露在某种你无法用语言表达、且令人极其崩溃的境遇中，以至于你的身体系统认为你必须在那个时刻被带离现场才能存活下来，它就会这么做。这本质上就是冷冻反应（freeze response），你会解离并与这段经历切断联系，实际上并没有真正完全经历它。而且我认为我们的大脑——这简直是个奇迹。当我们把它贴上失调的标签时，我们实在是错得离谱，因为你的身体系统里居然有这样一种机制，它会说：“你知道吗，这件事，我们选择退出。”
We're going to push this all the way down because the other thing that happens is that often you're in a situation where your system decides that there is no one who can provide a relational home. That, for example, if let's say the abuser is a parent or someone in your family, there is no safe space to go because to do so would be to risk your, you know, primary location in the world with your family. And so, and you're like six. So what are you going to, you know, what are you going to do? And so I think that our brains do this miraculous calculus whereby they decide what we can cope with and what we can't. And I think it's really important that we don't disturb that
“我们要把这一切深深地压下去，”因为随之而来的另一个情况往往是，你身处这样一种境地：你的身体系统认定，没有任何人能为你提供一个情感上的避风港。比如，假设施虐者是你的父母或你家里的某个人，你根本无处可去，因为如果那样做，就会危及你在家庭中赖以生存的核心地位。而当时你才六岁。那你又能怎么办，你知道吗，你能做什么呢？所以我想我们的大脑会进行这种神奇的精密计算，从而决定我们能应付什么、不能应付什么。我认为非常重要的一点是，我们不要去打扰它，
because what needs to come up will come up. And it will come up in the format that it has decided that it should come up in. So you might not remember, we have this like, I think, missed idea that if there is a trauma in the past, we have to go diving for it. you know, and go do a bunch of ayahuasca and find out exactly what it is and relive it in all of its, you know, awful glory. And we know that that's not true. We know that if you show up in adulthood with a set of behaviors, it's important that you work with those behaviors so that you can live
因为该浮现的终究会浮现。它会以它所决定的那种格式浮现出来。所以你可能记不清了，我们有一种错误的想法，认为如果过去有过创伤，我们就必须去潜水般地探寻它，你知道的，去服用一堆死藤水（ayahuasca），精确地找出那是什么，并在它所有的、你知道的、可怕的荣耀中重新体验它。但我们知道事实并非如此。我们知道，如果你在成年后表现出一系列的行为模式，重要的是去处理这些行为，这样你才能过上
a life that is more fulfilling. You don't always need to go back and uncover the thing that your brain is trying to hide from you, you know? I really love that explanation and I love how you put that, that we don't need to go diving for a traumatic experience, it will come up, perhaps even when we feel safe as well, when we feel like we're ready, yeah, like we're ready to experience it. That kind of leads to my next question, which is that how do we manage our trauma, trauma that maybe is concealed from us, but also trauma that is not concealed from us and very present in our lives and really taking up space that we wish could be devoted to other things. Yeah, yeah. Yes, that's the million dollar question.
更加充实的生活。你并不总是需要回过头去揭开那些你大脑试图对你隐瞒的事情，对吧？我真的很喜欢这个解释，我也很喜欢你的这种说法：我们不需要像潜水一样去搜寻创伤经历，它自己会浮现出来，甚至可能在我们感到安全的时候，在我们觉得自己准备好时——是的，就像我们准备好去经历它一样。这自然引出了我的下一个问题：我们该如何管理创伤？那些被隐瞒在心底的创伤，以及那些没有被隐瞒、就存在于我们生活中、并且真正占据了我们希望留给其他事情的空间的创伤？是的，是的。是的，这就是那个价值百万美元的问题。
So I think there's three steps here, and I can unpack each of them. The first is to notice it. The second is to validate it. The third is to integrate it. And I think these are healing from trauma actually isn't rocket science. We've known more or less how to do it since about the 1800s at the absolute or like later. Like it's possible we've known that for a lot longer. That's just when we started writing about it in a formal psychological way.
所以我觉得这里有三个步骤，我可以把它们一一拆解。第一步是察觉它。第二步是接纳它。第三步是整合它。我觉得从创伤中疗愈其实并不是什么火箭科学。大概从19世纪开始，或者更晚一些，我们多多少少就知道该怎么做了。甚至可能我们知道的时间要长得多。那只是我们开始用正式的心理学方式把它写下来的起点。
we create so much noise and problem for ourselves with shame and the way that we talk about our symptoms and so going back to the first one notice it I think that if we could view our bodies as the barometers that they are we could realize that our bodies and our systems are adaptive and they are giving us data all the time 24-7 your body is giving you important data about what it needs, what it's going through, and what needs to happen next. And so I think just kind of if you imagine, like, turning your radio dial to the channel of your nervous system and finding out, like, even the most simple things, which we do not typically think about, what do you feel when you feel relaxed?
我们用羞耻感以及我们谈论症状的方式，给自己制造了太多的杂音和麻烦。所以回到第一步，察觉它。我认为，如果我们能把身体看作是一个气压计，我们就会意识到，我们的身体和生理系统具有适应性，它们无时无刻、24/7都在向我们提供数据。你的身体一直在向你提供关于它需要什么、它正在经历什么、以及接下来需要发生什么的重要数据。所以我想，如果你试着想象一下，比如，把收音机调到你神经系统的频道，去弄清楚哪怕是最简单的事情——这些通常是我们不会去想的：当你感到放松时，你有什么感觉？
What do you feel when you feel energized and excited? What do you feel when you feel upset? Like, in your body, what is that experience like? when you're nervous do you get a stomach ache do you start sweating do you turn red like everyone is a little bit different and it's so important to kind of tune in and figuring out to figure out what your body is telling you because that's the key to noticing that you have trauma to begin with yeah because your body will be setting off an alarm in a situation when there's no need for an alarm but you might have been experiencing that for so long that you don't even notice that the alarm's going off
当你感到充满活力和兴奋时，你有什么感觉？当你感到沮丧时，你有什么感觉？在你的身体里，那种体验是怎样的？当你紧张时，你会肚子痛吗？你会开始出汗吗？你会满脸通红吗？每个人的反应都略有不同，所以学会去倾听并弄清楚你的身体在告诉你什么，是至关重要的，因为这是你意识到自己身上存在创伤的关键。是的，因为当根本没有必要拉响警报时，你的身体却在某种情况下拉响了警报，而你可能已经经历这种状态太久了，甚至都没有察觉到警报正在拉响。
Yeah, absolutely. And so it's the first one is to notice. To notice it. The second is to validate it. So we are very tempted in our society to go to war with our feelings and to treat our symptoms as if they are to be managed before we integrate them. Yeah. And so if something inconvenient is going on in my body, like I'm just going to shove it all the way down until it goes away. And that will work for a certain amount of time and then it will stop working and everything will implode.
是的，完全如此。所以第一步是察觉。去察觉它。第二步是接纳它（validate it）。在我们的社会中，我们很容易与自己的情感开战，把症状当作在整合之前必须加以控制和压制的东西。是的。所以如果我的身体里发生了什么不合时宜的事情，比如我只想把它死死压下去，直到它消失。这种方法在一定时间内确实有效，但随后它就会失效，一切都会彻底崩溃。
That for sure happened to me. And so validate what you're feeling instead of going to war with it, instead of shaming it and saying, I should be over this by now. Why am I still feeling this way? I'm an adult. I'm 23. I shouldn't be this sad over this break. You know, whatever it is that you're shaming yourself.
这种事绝对在我身上发生过。所以，去接纳你所感受到的情绪，而不是与它开战，不要去羞耻它，不要说：“我早该走出来了。为什么我现在还有这种感觉？我都成年了。我都23岁了。我不应该为这段分手这么伤心。”不管你用什么方式在羞耻自己。
And then the third thing is integrated, which requires a couple of other steps. So what we're working on here is figuring out what needs to be integrated, right? How is the memory fragmented? What is still sticking out? Two, what are some ways that you can grow? around yourself as you lean into working with the memory file. So how do you recalibrate your nervous system essentially? And three is getting the memory to kind of more or less conform to the formatting of your
第三步是整合，这需要另外几个步骤。所以我们在这里要做的，是弄清楚什么需要被整合，对吧？记忆是如何碎片化的？有什么东西还在隐隐作痛？第二，当你开始着手处理记忆档案时，有哪些方式可以围绕自己进行成长？本质上，你如何重新校准你的神经系统？第三，让这段记忆多多少少符合你
other memories so that it's not continuing to come up in symptoms or behaviors that show up like in your relationships or at work or ways that are getting in the way of your future. Yeah. I really, I'm listening to that being like, oh, I'm taking notes. I am taking notes because I do feel like that integration, that integration point that you've mentioned is so fascinating. And I was thinking, as you were saying, that like, what are my memories shaped like? Do they have a beginning, middle, and end?
其他记忆的格式，这样它就不会继续以症状或行为的形式不断涌现出来——比如表现在你的亲密关系中、工作中，或者任何阻碍你未来的方式中。是的。我听着这些，心里想：哦，我在记笔记。我真的在记笔记，因为我深感你提到的那个整合点实在是太迷人了。我当时就在想，正如你所说：我的记忆形状是怎样的？它们有开头、过程和结尾吗？
And is the reason why some of those files still sticking out because they don't have an end yet and I need to write that end for them. And I think that that is like the idea perhaps of closure of like, okay, why does this memory and why does this event feel like it is still a part of my life when I haven't seen this person in years or I no longer live at this place where this happened or I'm no longer an infant, I'm no longer a child, I'm a fully formed adult, how come this memory doesn't have an end? Why do you think we find that with certain events or experiences that they continue to kind of be part of our storyline even when we don't want them to be?
为什么其中一些档案仍然挥之不去？是不是因为它们还没有一个结局，而我需要为它们写下这个结局？我觉得这就好比是对“释怀（closure）”的概念的理解：为什么这段记忆和这个事件在我已经几年没见过这个人、或者我不再住在发生这件事的地方、或者我不再是个婴儿、不再是个孩子而是一个完全成熟的成年人之后，依然觉得它是我的生活的一部分？为什么这段记忆没有一个结尾？为什么你认为某些事件或经历会让我们觉得它们挥之不去，甚至在我们不希望它们存在时，仍然成为我们故事线的一部分？
Yeah, that's a great question. I think there's a thousand reasons. I'm kind of, I'm laughing because I just got this. I'm writing a response to someone who just wrote to me about, you know, a friendship that broke up 50 years ago, 50 years ago. Oh my goodness. Still hung up on. And I was, that's, I had the exact same response when I read the email like, what?
是的，这是一个很好的问题。我想原因有一千种。我有点——我之所以在笑，是因为我刚刚收到了一封信。我正在给一个刚给我写信的人回复，信里谈到一段50年前破裂的友谊，整整50年前。哦天哪。到现在还放不下。我的反应跟你读邮件时的反应一模一样：什么？
Is that even possible? That's actually scary. I don't want that to be me. That literally is. Exactly. I'm like thinking, because I've got, I've, I've got 50 years left. I could, I've still got time. Like, what is the things in my life right now that are going to be?
这怎么可能？这其实挺吓人的。我可不想变成那样。字面意思上确实如此。完全是这样。我想着，因为我还有——我还剩50年呢。我可能——我还有时间。那么，我生命中现在有哪些事情将来会
That are going to be, haunting me. Sweeting 50 years later. Yeah. Yeah. And I think it's because, you know, number one, you mentioned a while ago about agency.
成为那种——
We don't think of ourselves as having agency over our stories and over our psychology. And if we can empower ourselves to get a little bit more knowledge, that is a huge step forward to figuring out what we need. If we go back to memory files for a second,
50年后依然在困扰我的事情？是的。是的。我想这是因为，第一，你刚才提到了自主权（agency）。
so every memory file needs to have a story, like what happened, beginning, middle, and end. emotional content, what is the feeling of that story? Is it funny? Was it sad? Was it both? Whatever? And then a set of meaning tags. What is the significance? How does this fit within your larger story arc? And I think that last piece is, I mean, you can work in a memory in any of those pieces, but I think the last piece is one of the places that leaves things open for us.
我们不认为自己对自己的故事和心理拥有自主权。如果我们能赋能自己去获取更多知识，这将是弄清我们真正需求的重要一步。如果我们再次回到记忆档案上，
We assign the wrong significance to something. And so a breakup instead of becoming a learning opportunity that was really sad, and tragic, but still a learning opportunity, becomes the reason that you are, you know, disorganized attachment and the reason you will always be alone. And in some sense, again, going back to the brilliance of the system, the brain knows that that significance you've assigned is wrong. And so it keeps pushing it forward and saying, you better look at this again. You better look at this again. And so again, if you go back to noticing, like, what is coming up for yourself what is repeatedly what are you repeatedly remembering and then instead of judging that
那么每一个记忆档案都需要有一个故事，比如发生了什么：起因、经过、结果。还有情感内容，这个故事的感觉是什么？它搞笑吗？悲伤吗？还是两者兼有？随之而来的是一组意义标签。它的重要性是什么？这如何契合你的宏大故事弧光？我认为最后这一点——我的意思是，你可以在记忆的任何一个部分进行处理，但我认为最后这一点正是让问题对我们保持开放的地方。我们给某件事情赋予了错误的意义。因此，一场分手没有变成一个虽然悲伤、悲惨但依然充满学习机会的经历，反而变成了你——你知道的——表现为不安全型依恋的原因，也成了你注定永远孤独的原因。某种意义上，再次回到身体系统的精妙之处，大脑其实知道你赋予的这种意义是错误的。所以它不断地把它推到你面前，说：“你最好再看看这个。你最好再审视一下这个。”所以同样地，如果你回到察觉上，比如：什么东西在你的脑海里浮现？是什么在不断重复？你一直在反复记起什么？然后，与其去评判它，不如去问：
asking like okay what's here yeah like so this friendship came up that like that ended 50 years ago what's here for you about that yeah and do you think it's like some so i you know it's hard not to apply these to our own experiences right like you're giving me these examples and i'm thinking about this one particular event in mind and do you think it's because it points to like a deeper truth that we think we have about ourselves? Like, do you think that in that instance of that, of that guy that or that man, that perhaps it's like, it's not about the friendship breakup. It's really, that's kind of a proxy for something deeper around how he feels about himself.
“好吧，这里面到底有什么？”比如，这段已经结束了50年的友谊浮现了，这其中对你来说意味着什么？是的。你觉得这是否指向了——你知道的，很难不把这些应用到我们自己的经历上，对吧？你给我的这些例子，让我想起了我心中某个特别的事件。你觉得这是因为它指向了某种我们对自己抱有的更深层的真相吗？比如，你觉得在那个男人的例子中，也许这根本不是关于友谊的破裂，而是关于他如何看待自己的某种更深层感受的替代投射？
Where do you think that that comes from? Yeah, I mean, it's got to have significance somewhere, right? So it's got to be that he's got, I mean, I can guess. I wish I had more details because I could maybe guess more accurately. But I would imagine that he's got a deep-seated fear, that he's worried that he's a bad person. And so a friend ghosting him without explaining it has left this open wound of like, if I could just have this one person's validation, then I would know for sure that I'm not a bad person, which is, of course, false.
你觉得这种感觉是从哪里来的？是的，我的意思是，它一定在某个地方具有某种意义，对吧？所以它一定意味着他有某种——我的意思是，我可以猜一下。我要是有更多细节就好了，那样我可能猜得更准一些。但我猜他内心深处有一种根深蒂固的恐惧，他担心自己是个坏人。所以一个朋友在没有解释的情况下“ghost”（人间蒸发）了他，这就留下了一个未愈合的伤口：如果我能得到这一个人的肯定，那我就能确凿地知道我不是个坏人。当然，这是假的。
but like when when things kind of gain an outside significance it's usually because there's an underlying fear or a story you're telling yourself that you're or a story that's been told that you're trying to distance yourself from so maybe he doesn't think he's a bad person but someone has his mom always said that and she's maybe you know and so he's he's worried that that that validates that um there could be a thousand things but I think usually when something is open like that, that there is something, like I sometimes ask clients, like, what's the fear beneath the fear? Yeah.
但当事情获得了超出本身的意义时，通常是因为背后有一种潜在的恐惧，或者有一个你在对自我讲述的故事，或者有一个你正极力想与之拉开距离的故事。所以也许他并不认为自己是个坏人，但曾经有人——比如他妈妈总是这么说，也许吧——所以他担心这验证了那种说法。这可能有一千种原因，但我想，通常当某件事情像这样悬而未决时，背后一定有某种东西。我有时会问客户：“恐惧之下的恐惧是什么？”是的。
So don't tell me rejection. What happens if you get rejected? What is that reveal? And usually it's something really primary, like, oh, my, you know, that I'm, that I am evil or that my mother was right, that I didn't deserve to live, you know, like some horrible thing that hasn't been processed from forever ago. Wow. And I guess bringing it back to that breakup example that we were using, it's like,
所以别告诉我你是害怕被拒绝。如果你被拒绝了会发生什么？那暴露了什么？通常这是一种非常基础的东西，比如：“哦，我其实是个恶魔”或者“我妈妈是对的，我不配活在这个世上”——诸如此类一些从很久以前开始就一直没有被处理过的可怕念头。哇。我想这回到了我们刚才用过的那个分手的例子，那就是：
oh, this not only has this distorted, this idea of my future, but then additionally, maybe it's pointed to the fact that you do think you're unlovable because that's how your parents treated you or that because you did experience childhood bullying where you never felt like you were quite ready to be accepted by anyone else. So I just think that's so fascinating. And once again, points to that holistic perspective that sometimes we need to take when it comes to trauma that you cannot apply a one-size-fits-all methodology or, explanation to everyone's individual circumstances. I think that everyone is incredibly different
哦，这不仅扭曲了我对未来的看法，此外，也许它还指出了这样一个事实：你确实认为自己不讨人喜欢，因为你的父母就是那样对待你的，或者因为你经历过童年霸凌，让你觉得你从来没有真正准备好被任何人接纳。所以我认为这太迷人了。这也再次印证了那种整体性的视角：在面对创伤时，我们有时需要采取这种视角，因为你无法将一套“一刀切”的方法论或解释强加给每个人的个体处境。我认为每个人都极其不同，
and has a different narrative, as you were saying, this whole idea of a storyline. I've got one last question for you. And this is a question that I get all the time. And I always, I answer in a certain way, but I would love to see how you answer as someone who knows more than me. I feel like that is obviously very true. So the question is, does trauma ever go away? Can I ever live a life without trauma? So I am always like, yeah, I think so. But what do you think? It depends on what go away means. Yeah. Like I think sometimes the question gets framed up, can you heal? Is healing from trauma possible? The answer to that is absolutely. Is erasing trauma possible? If that's the frame you have on it? No, that's not possible. But it can be managed. And the way that we can explain this is by
并且拥有不同的叙事，正如你所说，这就是整个“故事线”的概念。我还有一个最后的问题。这是一个我经常被问到的问题。我总是用某种特定的方式来回答，但作为比我懂得多得多的专家，我很想知道你会如何回答。我觉得这个假设显然非常正确。所以问题是：创伤真的会消失吗？我能过上没有创伤的生活吗？我总是回答：“对，我想是的。”但你觉得呢？这取决于“消失”到底是什么意思。是的。我的意思是，有时这个问题被框定为：你能疗愈吗？从创伤中疗愈是可能的吗？这个问题的答案是：绝对可以。抹去创伤是可能的吗？如果你是从这个框架去理解它？不，那是不可能的。但创伤是可以被管理的。我们可以这样来解释：
going back to those memory files. Like if I open the file cabinet and I take out the file of the morning that my father died and I start talking about it, I'm going to feel sad because it was a sad day. That memory file has sad as the emotional content, right? That doesn't mean I haven't healed. That doesn't mean that the trauma is still present, that it's getting in the way of my life. If I go to tell you the story and this happened a long time ago, if I go to tell you the story and I cry for three days and can't go to work, that's a sign that the emotional content is outsized and still needs integrating. Or if I tell you the story and there's no emotional content, that's also a sign of an issue. But our memory files are supposed to have feeling.
回到那些记忆档案。如果我打开档案柜，拿出我父亲去世那天早晨的档案并开始谈论它，我会感到难过，因为那确实是一个悲伤的日子。那份记忆档案的情感内容就是“悲伤”，对吧？但这并不意味着我没有疗愈。这并不意味着创伤仍然存在并妨碍了我的生活。如果我把这个故事讲给你听——这发生在很久以前——如果我讲这个故事时哭了三天，甚至无法去上班，这就表明这种情感内容过大，仍然需要被整合。或者，如果我讲这个故事时没有任何情感波动，这也是一个问题的信号。但我们的记忆档案本来就应该包含情感，
that's that's how our brains are are built and so if the question is will i ever stop feeling the answer is no but the feelings change in in in the way that they are expressed hugely when you integrate the memories and i think that that's hopeful because it is it's so helpful I think the thing I always think about is around integration, like you will get better at making. This event will no longer define you. And I think that in a lot of the things that happened to us, especially in our 20s, right,
这是我们大脑的构建方式。所以如果问题是“我是否会停止感受”，答案是“不会”。但当你把记忆整合之后，这些感受在表达方式上会发生巨大的变化。我认为这给人带来了希望，因为它是如此有用。我总是想到的是关于整合的事情：你会越来越擅长处理。这件事将不再定义你。我认为在很多发生在我们身上的事情中，特别是在我们20多岁的时候，对吧，
there isn't, we haven't had the diversity of experiences to see in hindsight that we have a lot of years ahead of us. We've only really had like max like 29 years if you're in your late 20s. And even by then, I feel like you're kind of encroaching on the 30 space, but particularly people, in their early 20s, right? Like five years ago, you were still a child. You have no hindsight of what five years means.
我们还没有经历过足够多样化的经历，无法在事后回看时明白我们前方还有很多年。我们真正经历的时间最多也就大概29岁，如果你处于20多岁末期的话。甚至到那个时候，我觉得你已经在逼近30岁的门槛了，但特别是对于那些处于20多岁出头的人来说，对吧？五年前，你还只是个孩子。你根本无法回过头来看五年到底意味着什么。
You have no hindsight around the other things that are going to take precedence over the bad times and over the hard memories. Like, I think that's something that I really had to realize, you know, my, yeah, I'm not going to get into that. I'm not going to trauma dump on this call, but yeah, I just think about this one experience that I had. And for a couple of years,
你无法预见到其他那些将取代黑暗时期和痛苦记忆的美好事物。我想这是我真正意识到的一点，你知道的，我的——是的，我不扯远了。我不会在这场通话里疯狂倾倒创伤垃圾（trauma dump），但是的，我只是想到了我曾有过的那段经历。在那几年里，
felt like that memory was like the core of my identity and that like everything could be looped back around how hard that was and then suddenly like not suddenly there was also work but different things began to crop up that were really joyful and that I wanted to find a place for and I kind of had to rearrange the luggage of my brain I had to like rearrange my storage space and push that memory to the side a little bit, it could no longer have like a whole massive platform in the middle. And perhaps that's how I, that's how I see integration of is that, you know, that piece of luggage is still there, but it's not like your primary piece of luggage. Or it's like, I always think about it as well in terms of like, you know, when you buy like a new
我感觉那段记忆就像是我身份的核心，一切都可以归结为“当初有多艰难”。然后突然间——也不是突然间，生活中还有工作——各种不同的、真正充满喜悦的事情开始出现，我想要为它们找到一席之地。我不得不重新整理我大脑中的行李，我不得不重新整理我的储藏空间，把那段记忆稍微推到一边，它不能再占据中央的整个巨大平台了。也许这就是我——这就是我对整合的理解：那件行李依然在那里，但它不再是你最主要的行李了。或者就像我一直想的那样，就像你买了一件
t-shirt and you like wear that t-shirt for like ages and ages and ages. But suddenly it's going to be replaced by your new favorite item of clothing. And it's not that that item is still not important and still didn't have a part of your life as in your photos. And nobody can ever take away the significance that it had. Like that's critical. Like you might not wear it anymore. It might just be a memory.
新T恤，然后你会连续穿它好久好久。但突然之间，它会被你新的最爱衣物所取代。这并不是说那件衣服就不重要了，或者它没有在你的照片里占据过一部分生活。没有人能抹杀它所具有的重要意义。这至关重要。你可能不再穿它了，它可能只成了一段记忆。
But like that was for that period of time your favorite thing. Yeah. You know? And I think like sometimes we resist progress and healing because we think we can lose what we've already lost, but you can't. Yeah. That's such a beautiful way to put it. Well, I want to say thank you so much.
但在那段时间里，那就是你最喜欢的东西。对吧？我想，有时我们抗拒进步和疗愈，是因为我们觉得我们会失去已经失去的东西，但其实你不会。是的。这真的是一种非常美妙的表达方式。好吧，我非常感谢你。
Is there anything else that you want to say around? trauma, a misconception, something you think we need to know that perhaps we haven't spoken about yet. I think I want a listener to know if you're struggling with trauma and the after effects, the traces the trauma has left, that it won't always feel like this, that you are not alone, even if trauma has tricked you into thinking you are, and that healing is possible. There's so much more life to live. Yeah.
关于创伤、某个常见的误解，或者有什么你认为我们需要知道、但我们还没来得及谈论的事情，你还有什么想补充的吗？我想对听众说：如果你正在与创伤及其余波、创伤留下的痕迹作斗争，请记住，这种情况不会一直持续下去；你并不孤单，即使创伤曾欺骗你让你觉得孤单；而且，疗愈是可能的。生命中还有更多的美好等着你去经历。是的，
that's such a beautiful way to put it. Thank you so much for coming on. This is perhaps one of my favorite conversations. I also feel like. That's so flattering. No, it was really amazing. Sometimes I honestly was in this call being like, oh my God, I didn't even have to pay for therapy this week.
这真的是太美妙的表达了。非常感谢你能来。这或许是我最喜欢的对话之一。我也觉得——这太让人受宠若惊了。不，这真的很棒。有时候在这通电话里，我老实觉得：“天哪，我这周甚至都不用付心理咨询费了。”
Cancel that appointment. Done. Like, it was actually, I learned so, so much. I'm going to. Oh, yay. I was so glad. Yeah. So also, I really want to plug your book,
直接取消那个预约。搞定。真的，我学到了太多太多。我要去——哦，太好了。我太高兴了。是的。所以，我真的很想为你的书做个宣传，
because this was only like a 45. minute conversation and there is so much more as anyone can imagine to this topic and to this conversation so where can they find you where can they hear more from you so the book is called unbroken the trauma response is never wrong it's available on amazon and anywhere you get books we're working on getting it into many different countries so it's being translated in a couple different languages you can find me on tictock and instagram it's the same handle it's just mc. phd and I'm always talking about trauma and trying to demystify the symptoms and help people heal. There we go.
因为这只是一场45分钟的对话，正如任何人所能想象的，关于这个话题和这场对话还有太多内容。所以人们可以在哪里找到你？在哪里可以听到更多你的分享？这本书叫《完好无损：创伤反应永远没有错》（Unbroken: The Trauma Response is Never Wrong），在亚马逊以及所有出售图书的地方都可以买到。我们正在努力将它带到更多不同的国家，所以它正在被翻译成几种不同的语言。你可以在TikTok和Instagram上找到我，用户名是一样的，就是mc.phd。我一直在谈论创伤，努力揭开这些症状的神秘面纱，并帮助人们疗愈。就是这样。
Something that I think we all need. Make sure you add that to your feed. A bit of a Dr. Seuss rhyme there. But I do think that it's something that we need to speak about more concisely, I think, and integrate more into our conversations around what really is trauma, what does it mean? and how can we move forward around that, especially in our 20s? So I want to say a huge thank you for coming on board just to share your wisdom. Oh my gosh, thank you so much for having me.
我想这是我们所有人都需要了解的。确保把这个加到你的动态里。这里有点像苏斯博士（Dr. Seuss）的韵脚。但我确实认为，我们需要更简明地谈论这个话题，并将其更多地融入到我们关于“到底什么是创伤”、“它意味着什么”、以及“我们如何才能从中走出来”的讨论中，特别是在我们20多岁的时候。所以我要非常感谢你今天能来分享你的智慧。哦天哪，非常感谢邀请我。
Yes, that's so lovely. Please come back. We'll do a part to do for sure. Oh, my gosh. Absolutely. Whatever we want. Yeah, done. And as always, thank you so much for joining us today.
是的，太棒了。请一定要再来。我们一定做个第二期。哦，天哪。绝对的。随时奉陪。是的，说定了。一如既往，非常感谢大家今天的收听。
If you enjoyed this podcast and feel cool to do so, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now, really helps this show to grow and reach new people. Also makes my day and I would really appreciate it. If you have an episode suggestion or just want to be part of the community, please follow along at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. You will be the first to know about new episodes, new guests like The Amazing MC, and all that is going on behind the scenes.
如果你喜欢这个播客，并且愿意的话，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评，这真的能极大地帮助节目成长并触达更多新的人。这也绝对能让我开心一整天，我对此感激不尽。如果你有任何节目建议，或者只是想成为我们社区的一员，请在Instagram上关注That Psychology Podcast。你将第一时间了解新节目、像了不起的MC这样的新嘉宾，以及幕后发生的一切。
So thank you so much for listening and we will see you next week. Hey, what's good, y'all? you're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
非常感谢大家的收听，我们下周见。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯（Kier Games）主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都觉得不够安全去开展的坦诚对话，而你正与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士一起进行这些对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
有多少男人穿着铠甲。这向世界释放出一个信号：你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这起怀孕事件似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同态恋者。迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。
This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura, Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
这里是《被困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立坚韧力的秘诀。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。输入单词“TWO%”。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友。听女性朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，就在 iHeart 广播应用、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在任何你收听播客的地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人录制。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。